THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
I'M BRET BAIER.
WE ARE COMING TO YOU TONIGHT
FROM THE RONALD REAGAN
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY IN
SIMI VALLEY, CALIFORNIA.
MORE ON WHY I AM HERE A BIT
LATER IN THE SHOW.
WE BEGIN ON THE OTHER COAST
HOWEVER, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
MEETS WITH THREE OF HIS TOP
NATIONAL SECURITY OFFICIALS
AFTER CALLING FOR A MAJOR
INVESTIGATION INTO REPORTS THE
FBI HAD A PLANT, AN INFORMANT,
SPY, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL
IT, AND HIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ESPECIALLY WANTS
TO FIND OUT WHAT HIS PREDECESSOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA KNEW ABOUT IT.
JUDGING BY HIS TWEETS, THE 45TH
PRESIDENT CLEARLY CONSIDERS THIS
PART OF A BIG CONSPIRACY.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
>> IN A STATEMENT LATE TODAY THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SAID
THERE IS AN AGREEMENT FOR THE
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY TO
IMMEDIATELY BRING TOGETHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES WITH CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS SO THAT LAWMAKERS CAN
VIEW THE HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
RECORDS THEY REQUESTED LONG AGO.
A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL SAID THE
PRESIDENT'S CONCERNS ABOUT AN
ALLEGED FBI INFORMANT WOULD BE
RAISED AT THE MEETING WHICH
INCLUDED DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO WAS OVER
SEEING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
PROBE.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND DAN COATS.
AFTER THE PRESIDENTS WEEKEND
TWEED CALLING ON THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO INVESTIGATE CLAIMS
ABOUT THE INFORMANT, THE
DEPARTMENT QUICKLY AND ON SUNDAY
THE EXPANSION OF AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION INTO ALLEGED
GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE ABUSE.
THE NEW OF INQUIRY WILL CONSIDER
WHETHER THERE WAS ANY
IMPROPRIETY OR POLITICAL
MOTIVATION AND HOW THE FBI
OBTAINED SURVEILLANCE WARRANTS
WERE USED INFORMANTS TO COLLECT
INTELLIGENCE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT TOLD FOX'S
MARTHA MacCALLUM THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS CLARITY AND
CLOSURE.
A SPEAKER THE PRESIDENT THINK IS
GRATEFUL THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WAS GOING TO HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL LOOK INTO IT
AND DETERMINE AND ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS NO SURVEILLANCE DONE
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
AGAINST OUR CAMPAIGN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE VERY
TROUBLING TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS IF THAT TOOK PLACE.
>> A SOURCE TELLS FOX NEWS THE
REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE AND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES, DEVIN NUNES AND TREY
GOWDY, WANT A DISCRETE SET OF
RECORDS ABOUT 200 RELATED TO THE
INTELLIGENT SOURCE AND WHETHER
THEIR WORK WAS USED IN THE
RUSSIAN CASE OR TO OBTAIN
SURVEILLANCE WARRANTS ON CARTER
PAGE, A TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE.
>> WE ARE ASKING, GIVE US THE
DOCUMENTATION USED TO START THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> ON THE SENATE FLOOR, MINORITY
LEADER SAID THE PRESIDENT'S CALL
FOR A PARALLEL INVESTIGATION SET
A BAD PRESIDENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEMS TO HAVE
A TERRIBLY MISGUIDED VIEW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
NARRATIVE ATTACKED HIS POLITICAL
INTERESTS AND PROSECUTE HIS
ENEMIES.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER
RUDY GIULIANI CLAIMS EARLIER
THIS MONTH HE SPOKE WITH SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION AND A MASSIVE
NUMBER ONE IF THE PRESIDENT
AGREED TO ADMIN JULY INTERVIEW.
GIULIANI SAID THE TWO MEN TALKED
ABOUT THE ALLEGED FBI INFORMANT.
GIULIANI SAID MUELLER'S
INTERVIEW WITH THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE CONTINGENT ON GIULIANI
HAVING ACCESS TO THE INFORMANT.
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT LAWMAKERS ARE
WILLING TO LEARN MORE DETAILS
ABOUT THE PROPOSED MEETING, THE
TIMING WHETHER ALL RECORDS
REQUESTED BY CONGRESS INCLUDING
THOSE RELATING TO AN ALLEGED FBI